l'hiver vous vous trouvez à l'instant
dans le centre de l'ukraine où il ya eu
des frappes non loin d'ici dans la nuit
quelle est la situation sur place
gulliver
oui justement avant qu'on parle des
apories jacky inquiète le monde entier
et l'ukraine en particulier on a eu hier
un rappel que à tous les endroits en
ukraine même dans les zones rurales
comme ici loin de toute ligne de front
il peut y avoir des frappes on a entendu
une explosion
en fin d'après midi hier
personnellement je pensais au départ que
c'était de la teneur mais ensuite il y a
eu des informations comme quoi des
cibles militaires dans cette région la
région de vinnytsia aurait été avait été
frappé les militaires ukrainiens l'ont
confirmé sans préciser le lieu exact de
la frappe ni s'il y avait des blessés
résultat de ces frappes mais c'était
encore une fois un rappel que il y à
vraiment des frappes de temps en temps
de longues distances à des cibles un peu
partout en ukraine et ce qui était une
particularité hier c'était qu'il n'y
avait pas eu des sirènes d'avertissement
avant et maintenant les ukrainiens ne
sont pas en mesure de préciser pour le
moment quel genre domicile a été utilisé
et pourquoi les alertes n'avaient pas
retenti comme dans la plupart des cas où
il ya des frappes à longue distance il y
a toujours les sirènes qui retentissent
avant